we've been talking about how important
it is not to allow ourselves to be so
distracted by the insane sayings and
doings of Donald Trump and Russia and
the entire thing that we forget about
the crazy stuff that the
republican-controlled House and Senate
are doing and it's continuing okay the
corrupt and deplorable Trump
administration continues to make
headlines forever to everything raised
ranging from ignorance to potential
crimes but meanwhile Republicans keep
passing disastrous truly disastrous
bills here's some of the latest utterly
insane bills that have been introduced
by Republicans some of which have passed
one or both houses of Congress okay we
have HR 861 introduced by Florida
Republican Matt Gaetz which would
abolish the Environmental Protection
Agency okay we have this bill up on the
screen for you and this is the committee
led by congressman Lamar Smith who
fought hard against investigations of
Exxon's climate fraud and the committee
recently retweeted a Breitbart article
that denied climate change okay they
retweet Breitbart articles that are
completely non science-based and they
have passed a bill which would
completely abolish the EPA that bill is
only in its beginning stages then we
have our buddy from Iowa Congressman
Steve King who introduced HR six one one
nine the choices in Education Act this
would get rid of all federal regulation
of schools so the Department of
Education would just be giving grants to
States to found that to fund voucher
programs disaster and by the way to get
this funding states would have to allow
parents to enroll their kids in any
public or private school in the state it
would loosen homeschooling regulations
and it would also get rid of healthy
food regulations in public schools even
with the regulations we have there are
some schools that have some really
really unhealthy food then we have
another bill HR 899 introduced by
congressman
Thomas Massie which would get rid of the
Department of Education altogether
forget about limiting their power let's
just get rid of the department
altogether called termination of the
Department of Education there's one
upside to that bill pad which is if you
get rid of the Department of Education
Betsy DeVos is gone since there would be
no department is that a silver lining to
look at that was the whole idea behind
putting Tom Price in charge of Health
and Human Services right putting Rick
Perry in charge of energy and now Betsy
DeVos for education yeah they're against
the department's yeah might as well we
also have hjr 69 okay this is House
Joint Resolution 69 this one actually
made it to the house and was passed a
few weeks ago now looking at what's
going on in the Senate this one would
remove many rules on recreational
hunting in Alaskan wildlife refugees the
bill would allow people to kill black or
brown bear cubs and their mothers if
you're hunting for sport why do you need
to kill the Cubs it would allow you to
kill any bear using traps or snares
again if you're hunting for sport what's
the sport Pat in using a snare to trap
and kill a bear it would also allow you
to kill bears from aircraft reminds me
of Sarah Palin and it would also allow
you to kill wolves and coyotes during
certain times of year which is sort of
like the least controversial part of
this I really don't get it what is the
sport in doing some of this stuff I have
no idea I don't even know if this is too
political in a sense because I don't
know if this really divides Republicans
and Democrats it's happening there have
also been many attempts made to repeal
Obamacare but we have a new bill to
repeal Obamacare introduced by
Congressman bill Flores which might
actually be the first one that a
president in the White House would sign
this is HR 370 thus bill is still in
committee we have from congresswoman
Diane black from Tennessee the defund
Planned Parenthood Act of 2017 which is
still in committee that bill has a
hundred and thirty three co-sponsors all
Republicans 1/4 of the entire house
remember that already Planned Parenthood
can't use federal funds for a bore
but if this bill is passed there will be
more Planned Parenthood clinics and
other similar clinics across the country
that would have to close their doors
they'd have to stop providing a large
array of health services to people who
otherwise can't afford them and a lot of
those services basically all of them
have nothing to do with abortion
diabetes testing cholesterol testing
vaccinations breast exams STD tests
birth control and at the clinics that do
stay open prices will skyrocket this
will affect low-income people this will
sort of defeat the purpose of Planned
Parenthood which is probably what
Republicans want to do we also have
proposed by Republicans the National
Right to Work Act this is HR 785 it
still is in a House committee seeking
approval introduced last month by
Congressman Steve King same guy who
introduced that school voucher bill I
told you about earlier this would
prevent unions from collecting fair
share fees from non-union employees so
basically they can free load off of
unions that are legally required to
represent them or what will actually be
the effect of this in many cases which
is obviously the goal of these
Republicans many unions will have to
shut down and no longer be able to work
for fair wages or adequate adequate
benefits etc one more to mention here
the mobilizing against sanctuary cities
Act this was proposed by congressman Lou
Barletta this would punish cities that
protect undocumented immigrants this
would affect over 400 localities
including New York City Los Angeles San
Francisco Chicago Detroit a very very
long list we also have the strangely
named prenatal non-discrimination act of
2017 introduced by Republican Trent
Franks this is awaiting review by the
Subcommittee on the Constitution and
civil justice this would criminalize
criminalized abortions performed on the
basis of the sex of the fetus of course
the real question is how do you know
under the law health care providers that
quote suspect that the patient is
seeking a sex selective abortion would
be required to notify authorities how do
you enforce this how do you enforce this
and just wanting to know the sex of your
fetus
might become suspect especially if the
pregnancy is unwanted to begin with so
Republicans all of a sudden I guess
fighting for gender equality I'm kidding
by the way it's absolutely bogus this
new trump presidency pat has done two
things number one it has caused so much
insanity that people are paying less
attention to what Republicans are doing
but it has also emboldened House and
Senate Republicans to do really horrible
things that we should be paying
attention to and I think there's this
idea that Trump right now is kind of a
liability and a headache for Republicans
that may be true down the road when
they're looking for re-election efforts
in 2018 and 2020 but for right now they
can do whatever they want oh yeah people
who even are media literate and pay
attention to the news everyday who watch
the Sunday morning talk shows and read
all the articles they're not even
getting this information because media
is mostly not covering it that's why and
yeah they are this is the Trump is
providing cover for the more pragmatic
and effective Republicans in the House
and Senate you've got to be aware of
this stuff this is the stuff where you
actually can call your representatives